So we're going to start off by talking about scopes and closures.
Since you really need to fully understand those aspects of functions and
variable access before we can move on to more advanced topics of
object-oriented programming.
Then we'll discuss the parameter this and prototype delegation, which
are the two main language features allowing for object-oriented JavaScript.
Finally, we'll cover a number of different ways that you can write JavaScript
classes and subclasses.
By the end of this,
you'll have a strong understanding of JavaScript's object-oriented features and
how the code you write impacts the interpreters in memory model as your
code is executing.